so we are on vacation this week we have
produced some extra content for the
YouTube channel and you'll be seeing a
lot of those clips and stories be
published during the week once we're
back we are going straight through to
the election in November but while we're
gone I've set up a little membership
special for our YouTube subscribers if
you go to david pakman.com slash
membership and you will notice by the
way the brand new david pakman.com
website it works better than the old
website it looks better than the old
website it performs better than the old
website really can't think about
anything about this new website that is
worse other than maybe the fact that we
have a relatively aggressively zoomed in
picture of me on the memberships page
page which i know is scaring a lot of
children and also some people's dogs
reportedly being scared by that picture
uh so anyway you go to david pakman.com
slash membership monthly or yearly you
select which one you want you take that
red dot and slide it to whatever price
you want to pay and then after you click
sign up you will be taken to this page
and in that coupon code field if you
type in the coupon code huge 50 huge 50
all one word hu GE 50 you will get a
major major fifty percent discount off
of your membership for life this is not
fifty percent off your first payment ok
this is fifty percent off for the
duration of your membership and again
this is coupon code huge fifty hu GE 50
because we're gone we are offering this
there's nothing better than coming back
to fifty or a hundred new members when
we get back from a vacation and then all
of a sudden they get the bonus show
jason and then their minds are
completely blown yeah thirty dollars a
year to hear an extra segment which is
going up and up and production value
every day well worth it I like how Jason
is now he has cued me to mention that
yes jason has brought any number of new
ideas to the bonus show which are going
to be continuing to improve it increase
the production of the members
only bonus show you're absolutely right
about that and we are talking about
three dollars a month or 30 bucks for
the year with that coupon code huge 50
sign up david pakman.com slash
membership will be back and straight
through to the election